brian's in morristown new jersey hey
brian welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you dave thanks for taking my
question how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so right now my girlfriend's in her
final year
of vet school and thankfully up until
this point
um her parents have been able to help
her
pay for all of vet school um and she
hasn't had to take out any debt um
however this year is her final year and
she'll be taking out about
45 000 um in loans
and and i'm
next week will be about five years that
i've been dating her and
honestly next year and a half or so i
intend to ask her to marry me and um
you're a speed demon
six and a half years dude you must be a
prize she's waiting on you
you know what she probably still has
another four years
of um residency to go in order to get a
specialization so yeah she's gonna far
out educate me that's what i've long
accepted
but my question is um how would you
recommend that i
help her tackle the debt
i'll say that right now my income
my standard income is about 90 000
however i'm planning on the net worth to
be
a little over 200 000 for the year
and right now my biggest expense monthly
is my uh rent which is about
uh 1900. however my
one of the things i was thinking of
doing is
um even before we potentially get
engaged or when we do get engaged when
she graduates
is come up with a plan of
her tackling fifty percent of her debt
from
her income and me try and
offer to cover rent yeah
what what's your thought on that i think
you're playing house before you're
married
um okay i wouldn't be paying bills of
for
anyone that i wasn't married to under
any circumstances
because of all the downsides
and it messes with the relationship as
well
your girlfriend or your fiance
has a different feeling when she walks
in the room and you're carrying you're
carrying the financial burden
um if it's your wife it's a different
thing because that
and once you once the preacher says and
now you are one we do this together it's
all together
so i would do one of two routes um
i would go one end of the spectrum or
the other to
maintain safety in the relationship the
legal standing
and the financial standing route number
one is you continue with the calendar
that you're using
and you just pile up a big old pile of
cash over on your side of the equation
so that when you come home from the
honeymoon you write checks
and all of her stuff goes away okay okay
and you can do it has the exact same
mathematical effect at the end of the
story yeah
it just doesn't in the meantime and by
the way the borrowing that if she's
doing it now
is not putting any strain on her today
it's when it comes due later that it'll
be a strain
yeah so it's not a big deal for to do to
do it that way
the second way is to reconsider your
calendar
and that sounds like uh get married now
or
sooner very soon and then we've just got
a combined income and a combined set of
goals
and you take your fabulous income and
plow her on through mets
through vet school yeah nothing wrong
with that plan either
i mean it's not like uh you guys ain't
been hanging out together you
meet her five and a half days ago in a
bar it's five and a half years ago
so you know that that's not an
unreasonable
consideration um
so uh uh because it you know unless
something really weird happens this is
probably going forward
for the way you've described it i guess
eventually but
uh but yeah it you know again you do
what you want to do i
uh i would have a tendency to go towards
the second one
just on a personal level on a relational
level
uh it just feels like there's just uh
this separation and we're trying to do
it together but we're not together and
it's like dragging out and it's already
drug out a long time anyway
and we're dragging it out even further
now and it's abuse
i i just like the cleanliness of going
ahead and getting married and
in terms of the the relationship the
legal
you don't have to worry about anything
and um
and that that's how i would do it so hey
thanks for the call and i would not buy
property
together when you're not married folks i
wouldn't combine
incomes combine assets when you're not
married you get yourself in trouble
so good question brian thank you for
calling in
so guys you're listening to it guys been
doing this for
30 plus years
and so i've seen all the bad stories too
when things don't turn out like they're
supposed to
he buys a house with his girlfriend they
shack up
she gets killed in a car wreck now he
owns a house with her mother
because there was no will and he's not
an heir he's just a boyfriend
four times i've seen that scenario
yuck